Consider the problem of
the matrix-matrix multiply operation,
C gets C+A*B.
Suppose we run this operation
on an ideal cash machine.
And let's make our usual
simplifying assumptions.
Namely, that the matrix is square, and
stuff conveniently divides other stuff.
Now if you want to minimize data
transfers in a memory hierarchy
one way is to reorganize the computation
to multiply b by b sub-blocks.
Again for simplicity let's
assume that b divides n.
The corresponding pseudocode algorithm
would look something like this.
Now to make this algorithm cache
efficient, you would just choose b so
that these three b by
b blocks fit in cache.
In other words, b ought to be
proportional to the square root of z.
Now there's a subtle detail here
about what fitting in cache means.
To see it, suppose the matrices
are stored in column major order.
That means the elements of each
column are laid out consecutively
in linear memory addresses,
with one column following the other.
This layout is common in
linear algebra packages,
though note that languages like C and
C++ assume,
by default, that a two dimensional
array uses row major order.
A little more formally,
the ij element maps to a linear address.
The offset is i + j * s, where s is the
stride or sometimes leading dimension.
It has to be at least n.
Now let's take any b by b
block of one of the matrices.
Let's say we just want to
fit this block into cache.
Then it has to be the case
that z is at least L squared.
In literature, this is sometimes
written as the following lower bound.
This condition is called
the tall-cache assumption.
The tall-cache assumption says
the cache should be taller in terms of
the number of lines than it is wide in
terms of the number of words per line.
Let's take a simple example.
Suppose our matrix block is
exactly the size of the cache z
which holds 16 words.
Now suppose the line size is four words.
In this case, the Tall-Cache Assumption
holds assuming the matrix is
stored in column major layout
columns would map to complete lines.
Now suppose instead that L
is equal to eight words,
in this case the Tall-Cache Assumption
does not hold.
Columns no longer fill full lines,
thus the four by four block
doesn't actually fit in cache even
though the cache has enough capacity.
Now the Tall-Cache Assumption is
actually a really interesting one.
It's basically an artifact of how
we chose to lay out the matrices.
Put differently, in a memory hierarchy
model and efficient algorithm might be
linked to your choice of data structure
and how you choose to lay out the data.
We'll see more examples
of this soon enough.